G M o WT o GI Joe recent TV years here
in downtown Los Angeles to cover the
Monsanto protests their protests we're
showing the world as much as we can that
Monsanto is out of line it is this is an
event that's occurring in 50 countries
worldwide with thousands millions of
people involved GMO means medical
genetically modified organisms yeah I'm
for labeling I mean what I'm really for
is eradication I would like to see no
GMOs anywhere I am a strong believer
that we need to get rid of GMOs
completely off of the whole globe they
are not tested enough for us to think
that they're safe what kind of health
problems does GM food cause I see I
don't even want to act like I know a
whole bunch I know that they're no good
and I know Monsanto is evil as far as I
know there's only been one long-term
study done which I couldn't you know I
couldn't tell you who did it or anything
but that study showed that I forget what
that one exactly show I've read some
studies about how they think cause you
know birth defects every single
scientific organization around the world
including nonprofits has come out and
said that these foods are safe for
people well like my sign says there
they're experimenting they don't know
that they don't know for sure and we're
an experiment tell me tell me 15 years
down the road what I'm going to be
telling my grandchildren when they they
have maybe they have a deformity I
couldn't tell you if there's a
scientific consensus I'm big
a lot of scientists out there that are
paid by these very corporations to say
but it's not happening I don't think
that it's even open for debate what the
scientists say like the the ones that
paid by the federal government no I
don't trust them well I think they're
they're mostly just all liars on this
play they're being paid
they're being paid to you know every
Health Organization pretty much say
vaccines are safe and I don't vaccinate
my children has created aluminum
resistance resistance we can repeat that
GMOs are safe for us I mean the best
thing to do is obviously just Google
Monsanto Monsanto Protection Act
Monsanto honeybees I mean use the
internet you know that's that's where
you're gonna get the good information it
stands to reason that GMOs are dumb and
stupid and poisoned and Monsanto must be
stopped me and my chicken here are here
to protest against the most evilest
corporation company in the world
Monsanto is evil they suck yeah
there shouldn't even be an issue we get
Monsanto out of our food there their
cups they made Agent Orange
GMO kills and makes everybody sick
completely so it's not good for you it's
made in a laboratory it's been altered
it's not from the earth now Joe it's not
from God so it's scary
anybody to say that GMO is good they're
getting profited or some type of
kickback or something to hide the real
truth
what about it they come out at Santa Jim
fruit juices
they're absolutely wrong I'm a licensed
practitioner so I will bypass all that
put my name on the line for it that it's
all a lying deceit it's again it's once
again it's for profit you know you have
to understand what to do it's about by
going the right direction by eating
organic food with no pesticides detoxing
juicing eating and drinking
pH water meditite and fasting water and
lemon for a week kills all disease we
have to old do this otherwise you crazy
gonna die you're ahead corn that just
came out of the ground
ten minutes after it snapped off the
stock from a real seed it's better than
sex real corn that is real corn is
better than sex
[Applause]
[Music]